[Musique]
elle est folle cette session vidéo jour
au début je me suis dit ça ça c'est pas
possible merci 6ème d'être là vous êtes
vous êtes élèves de cette classe je suis
étudiante à le business school vous pour
vous tout va bien vous avez les
renvoyant en parfaite forme merci d'être
là parce que c'est vrai que hier sur les
raisons on a tous halluciné comme vous
on entend dans la classe tout monde
hallucine qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait en fait faut savoir que ce prof
habituellement il est toujours de bonne
humeur c'est pas du toit comportement
normal c'est vous le disiez parce que
c'est voilà oui parce qu'il faut j'ai vu
plein de choses sortir sur twitter vous
le disais c'est un prof que vous aimez
bien oui c'est un prof de quoi c'est un
prof de 16e d'accord c'est quoi j'ai été
très polis excusez moi non vraiment
j'ai décroché la saga sur la corée non
c'est quoi ces économies asiatiques et
management d'accor donc c'est votre prof
ça se passe très bien avec lui depuis le
début de l'année oui en fait de base
était toujours souriant rigolo il fait
tout le temps des blagues jamais énervé
vous allez il arrive dans une ambiance
pas la même pendant quinze minutes je
parle pas il est très renfermé sur
lui-même après le cours reprend
normalement et déjà c'est une classe les
problématiques de base c'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya un problème et
les profs ils ont déjà fait virer une
professeure enfin si l'on classe voilà
et l'élève en question du coût commence
à le tutoyer à lui paraît assez mal le
prof lui demande de sortir mais on le
voit on le voit vous êtes en plein cours
là où c'est le début pour nom c'est le
début du cours parce qu'on risque on
voit debout il est pas encore installé
alors le l'élève en fait en fait la ccit
en fait la surveiller c'est quand le
prof lui demande de sortir d'accord donc
là il prépare ses affaires pour sortir
voilà et du coup me convient parce qu'il
parle et il lui dit ne me tutoyez pas et
l'élève en question continuer à tutoyer
et là monsieur du coup il a vrillé
il a fait ce geste déplacé que je ne
cautionne pas mais ça reste anormal et
c'est pas dans son comportement habituel
alors 6ème juste ok ce qui se passe donc
il arrive en cours c'est ça il élève
l'acquis ce qui prend la claque lui dit
quoi au départ y le tutoie pourquoi
comme ça il lui dit c'est vraiment juste
comme ça c'est on n'a pas compris
l'arrivée je disais quoi mais il lui
disait confiante on ne tutoie ion
c'était quoi les mots qui lui a dit bah
ils parlaient pas plus mal que ça va en
fait à la base il faisait déjà un peu le
commandant des rebelles perturber un peu
le cours d'accor et du coût du produit
déjà des problèmes avec cette élève le
prof ou pas extrêmement particulières
non non non non jusque là il ay la
veillée s'est dit tiens je suis citoyen
n'était pas été déjà énervé en fait il
n'est pas arrivé rigolo comme d'habitude
déjà énervé donc c'est pour ça que il a
aimé parce que là on va revoir la scène
c'est vrai que la claque est les
violences qu est ce qui se passe après
alors après il ya les lèvres qui sort il
les insultes qui fusent oui parce que
l'élève de choix qui veut voilà il veut
et on voit qu'ils aient regardé
il n'y aurait pas cette vision est ce
qui se passe après voulait parce
qu'après on voit pas c'est quoi les
autres élèves laissez pas en fait oui
toutes les classes sorte bastia un bruit
énorme tout le monde les sépare oui il
ya une autre vidéo du coup de l'autre
côté notre point de vue où on voit les
lèvres dans le couloir qui l'insultent
avec des insultes très grave d'accord je
vais pas les répéter mais c'est des mots
très forts qui sort aux professeurs et
le professeur et mis à part dans la dans
le bureau des cpe pour que tout ce
qu'elle est les courts après ont repris
normalement une fois que l'homme a été
évacué le prof a pu faire son pourquoi
donc il a repris cours normalement après
le professeur qu'est ce qui est servi ce
qui va se passer maintenant ou pas du
tout non balle les fin je pense que la
directrice va agir en conséquence voir
ce qui ce qui peut le faire parce que
j'ai vu qu'il y avait énormément déjà
deux choses qui sortent sur l'école en
dehors de ces ça mais c'est vous ça vous
fait de la peine de voir des choses
serait qu'il se retire et comme vous
êtes bien dans cette école oui moi je
suis là franchement c'est une bonne
école bah oui on a des bons professeurs
il y a je vois des rumeurs qui sortent
sont affligeantes en fait